hey guys we're at CES 2014 I'm standing
here with men's CEO of Razer and you
just unveiled project Kristine what am I
looking at yes well this is project
Kristine this is the world's most
modular PC designs concepts designed
right now and it's the first time we're
showing it off we've been working on it
for a pretty long time I mean it's very
unusual looking and I think that's got a
lot to do with the modular design are
each of these individual sections
different components absolutely so what
we've done is essentially we've really
focused on bringing out the best of the
PC now the PC there's always this
promise of being able to build your own
PC you know you can swap out any stuff
but you know most of us will know that
some of us are not so technically
inclined but you know guys like us we've
been working on it for a long time we
you know we can swap out a GPU in a
matter of seconds and but what we've
done is essentially we've taken the
entire architecture and we've broken it
up to as modular as possible so what we
want to do is to really get rid of
obsolescence we're gonna get rid of
incompatibility you want to be able to
get the most factory overclocked
components out there so if you look down
you know the side of it you've got GPU
GPU GPU CPU we've got a water cooling
reservoir I'm sorry did you say four
GPUs three GPUs over here so we've got
to try a semi GPU with that with a CPU
you know right over there so essentially
what we really want to do is show this
off as a concept design about two years
ago we showed project Fiona that had
incredible amount of response we won the
best of CES for that for best of gaming
and then we decided to build it so this
time around what we're really trying to
do is to show off what we've been
working on in our secret labs at Razer
and find out were the community things
of having the world's most modular PC so
maybe I can just take this out give you
an idea of so these are the modules
you've got a huge amount of connectors
over here and these are two cells double
sealing self-seeding mineral oil pipes
so essentially what you can do is to
just Jack it in as a module by module
basis if say you've got a new GPU coming
out it's easy boom Jack it out you put
it back in and boom you've got an
all-new GPU
fully compatible and it's just gonna run
out of the box and it's probably pretty
quiet to you if it's cooled by oil right
are there any fans present in this
absolutely not so what we've got
this is an entire mineral oil reservoir
right at the edge you can kind of see
the level over here and what we've got
is a huge amount of pipes and and
thermal cooling systems all within this
which is also built as a as a handle and
so obviously this is a couple years away
even though it looks pretty close to
finished at the moment I mean this looks
great I think one thing that's pretty
obvious and kind of curious is this
little screen up front what can people
expect here I see a few different
windows icons I see some status
indicators what's the extent of the
functionality the screen sure so the
front of the unit essentially you know
you've got a blu-ray disc reader writer
if you want to have one this is what we
call the fancy screen well internally
this is gonna be a cooler name for that
and then of course you've got the SSDs
or the hard disk is we want that but
this is an option of thoughts it's
optional you can get a fancy just well
not a fancy a standard power button you
just want to stand a power button but if
you want to have a all-encompassing view
of what's happening within your system
this is what we've got a bit of a
command center over here so you can
pretty much install to say look I like
to boot on on Windows 7 I like to put on
Windows 8 can install any OS that you
want so we want to keep this absolutely
open to every single person and you've
got for example status updates you know
what's happening status on of your of
your system and all of their of course
the cool Razer logo too and so if you
can install any operating system I'm
sure people are very curious about Linux
based on Valve's recent announcements
and initiatives is that something you
guys are considering down the road so
we're super excited about what valve is
doing and essentially what we want to do
is to keep this open so if somebody
wants to put Linux if he wants to put
Android he once put anything out there
we want to be able to allow the user to
do anything
he wants that's the nature of the PC to
be absolutely absolutely open so some of
the other cool stuff like we're
considering also at the same time is you
know buying a new PC is a bit of an
expense at one petter at one point of
time especially if you're gonna go for a
trial SLI rig out there so but because
of the modular nature of this PC one
thing that we could potentially even do
is to put this on a subscription model
so instead of having to - say it's so a
guy could say I like to sign up for a
top-of-the-line tier 1 PC so every time
you just pay like a monthly fee and then
essentially when the new GPUs come out
instead of him
go out and buy a new one and I'll buy
anything we just ship the new modules to
him you'll just take this BAM put it in
take the old ones and ship it back to us
that's very unusual kind of exciting we
are we're excited about it because this
pretty much allows for all of that so
instead of having to pay thousands of
dollars at you know a single shot there
could be a standard subscription fee and
you could have always at any point of
time the best possible PC at any
juncture that's great well thank you Ben
I really appreciate your time again this
is project Christine I'm sure we have a
lot more to learn thanks again stay
tuned in game spot for more coverage of
CES 2014 blow us on Twitter Facebook
YouTube thanks for watching